ok ich begrüße sie ganz herzlich in
diesem fall steht die nächste liga geben
sollte und auch die teilnehmer hier
diesen raum zu diesem thema möchte jetzt
ein bisschen mehr zum thema des seminars
uns eigentlich gegen abend wird auch
ganz gut bis der weiße angezeigt wird
ich sehe sie noch nicht online okay also
gut dann bin ich jetzt und mit dem sehen
können
worum geht's hier also ich möchte nicht
tauschen ihren vielen bildern und ja
gesagt die eule der minerva wie geht es
mit der einrichtung
die das dieses jahr war es dass das ist
das sinnbild für die philosophie
zugleich muss also wie kann es
selbstverständlich er mir diese
philosophie als eule mir ist in dem
terror ihrem vortrag lädt sie nicht
aktiv
es könne nicht genannt
ja vielleicht auch erst dann also ist
sie gehen dort wo die sache nicht ganz
klar zu tage treten das bedeutet in die
philosophie die mit ihnen dann zu denken
nachzudenken wenn es schon vor beiden
menschen passiert wenn also alle die
sich schon eröffnet haben am tag dann
kommt sie ist und macht ihr geld so dass
tagsüber passiert ist und ich möchte das
jetzt ein bisschen problematisieren
diese orientierung
beziehen sie mitglied an die
digitalisierung und kommen auch die
mauer darauf was das eigentlich ist und
ich möchte sich gegen theesen gegen
sitzen und zwar möchte sagen
so kam es dass man das heute bereits um
12 uhr
und so sieht sie aus das ist unsere
lukas sie was will ich damit sagen will
damit sagen wir wieder so philosophiert
wollen uns gedanken machen über das das
jetzt gerade stadt und das jetzt gerade
stattfindet und dieser welt ist zum
beispiel die digitalisierung und die
geben
kate ist immer digitalität jetzt ist
wenn jetzt ein bisschen mehr erklären
mit einem sieg wäre die erste
retrospektive uns gedanken machen was da
alles aufgeben das ist man gold jeweils
eine selbst schon anfang und die sache
selbst gerade schon am start ist und wie
sich zählt es wird auf alle
lebensbereiche zu beten dass sie und wir
wollen dieses mal die digitalisierung
unter dem philosophischen und hast du
jetzt angegebenes ich habe es ehrlich
jetzt gleich
ich sehe wir haben schon drein zu
schauen das ist gut aber okay jetzt
jemanden sagen haben sind die dass das
was sagen hast soll damit ist jetzt
beschreiben können sie erkennen was ihn
zu erblicken land ja auch nicht wohl
genau das ist welchem bereich der
technik gehört dass an analogen auch
ohne noch einfache mechanik oder dass es
mich hat das ist also ganz physikalisch
mechanisch stabile golden reicht eins
das andere
also zu schließen das ist ein junger und
dann sehen sie aus wie es nur ein zu
haben sie zwar als er erzählte dass
dieses eigentlich haben sie im film der
es noch drauf hat sich wird hier digital
wir sehen diese schaltkreise ganz rechts
und das ganze verschwindet ineinander
würde es hat ein ganz wie herrn künstler
gemacht nachdem sie zuvor eine
hilfskraft die auch nach den beiden wird
der grafisch dargestellt das ist den
bürgern von der jugendlichen sind
digital zahnräder regung mechanik und
plötzlich kommen 001 rein und da und das
recht über dann kann ich ja ebenfalls
eine ganz wichtige revolution die gerade
im gange ist die ganz ähnlich sein die
gegend wie die elektrifizierung oder der
verschieden
wir sind auch reflektieren dass das
einen zeitunterschied von
digitalisierung bisschen genauer doch
demnächst am 11
was sehen sie hier die bilder erscheinen
was ist das ja
auf einen menschen ein also sieht aus
wie datenströme richtig sieht ein
bisschen aus information gekommen
wenn man das tut was den tank gemacht es
stürmt ein aber nicht nur es wird noch
mehr schnee und stürmischen 1901 die
ordnen sich oder diese sich die
datenpakete ordnen sich bei einer
bestimmten form eines menschlichen
gesichts
so könnten sich andere richtung als
nicht nicht synthetisch nicht dauernd
sind was haben jetzt im endspiel
gegenüber dem vorhin was sehen sie jetzt
nur ernst nickel spielen wenn ich genau
den lebens oder ähnliches wissen sie aus
den menschen menschen gesichter auch
sowie künstlichen
also das ist jedenfalls eine person im
gesicht und ein schicker was er da auf
jeden fall gleich in den sinn kommt ist
es wichtig jetzt also inwiefern können
wir aus nullen und einsen etwas basteln
etwas konstruieren was am ende selbst
deckt geht es mal dieses bild würde
jetzt welche dem breitesten sie möchte
es auf alter und der himmel stellen
möchte jetzt auf zwei ganz wichtige
differenzen einkommen zum 1 1 und 4 zu
schauen und keine unter zurzeit ist
jetzt als täglich habe sie nichts wir
haben zeit wenn's einmal gitarrist die
technische seite da haben wir zum
beispiel könnten eingegangen zahnrad das
ist analog leben das immer das ist
digital sind 0 01
die technische seite oder gibt es auch
die digitalisierung werden ist die
vitalität die kulturell so ein bisschen
schwieriger digitalisierung ist also die
tatsache dass alles immer mehr getan
wird was auch immer jetzt geht dann ist
das ihr jetzt solche tablets in der hand
haben dass sie das ganze auf youtube
sehen können dass
digitalisierung zu tun genauso das
papierlose hören oder e mails schreiben
weil viele arbeiten neue arbeitswelt
geschaffen
das ist das digitalisieren das ist jetzt
im gegensatz dazu gegen die aktuellen
krisen masken jetzt geht alles geben und
darum digitalisierung wenn sie scheinen
gut ist
lediglich für den technischen
fortschritt durch ersetzen von analogen
durch die tastatur sind
ich habe auch vielleicht schon
mitbekommen welche kurz freien und
sozialen konsequenzen hat
das natürlich wenn wir die falschen
selbst meter ebene ist die reflexion und
haben sie wahrlich niveau zeigt sich
digital wenn sie sich nur technisch ist
das wahrzeichen stabilität frau ist
werden es die reflexion auch die ja zb
ich konnte mir kommen plötzlich von der
technik der digitalisierung jedes etwas
was die normativität also fragen nach
den wert ergeben dass gut oder böse gut
oder schlecht ist
wo könnte so was dem zentralen
automatisierung autonomen zwar in
schlichten autonomes fahren ist nicht
nur ein technischer aspekt sind es gibt
losen philosophen an der in münchen der
über doktorarbeiten
da zeigt sich dass plötzlich technische
seite digitalisierung eingang findet in
einen anderen diskurs was richtig ist
aber wahrscheinlich dem technischen
delegierten sondern mails an die moral
ist also hier findet technische aspekt
eingang in einer interessieren oder dies
sagten himmel ein tägliches reflektiert
von einer nun eben
also das ist auf jeden fall ein punkt
geht an die cdu sonst noch die
grundschule
der täter könnte beispiel geben naja
[Musik]
immerhin zu nehmen das was das auch
immer für barren musste fiel nun das
serum kategorie finanzsystem immer
wieder auf die gleichen dieser maximus
kann ihn jetzt wieder unternehmens 2 und
3 mittlerweile selbst die sanierung ist
die aufklärung her sehr gut da kommt
alles hier gibt es zwei schnelligkeit
die sagen diese informationen die wir
durch digitalisierung erhalten sie
schnell zugänglich erfolgsnachrichten
pearson education im internet eine
google suchanfrage bekommen sofort
information
das problem ist wir wissen nicht auf die
informationen richtig ist dort da
irgendwelche interesse dahinter stehen
dienst
sie werden gestreut technik ist
stichwort rechnen
ich kann da einfach was behaupten
internet jemanden freundin und ich
glauben sein müssen alle sagen sie das
ist ein problem für die aufklärung oder
gut
also wir bekommen eine art von von
medialität das medium der schrift und es
nicht nur gedruckt ist sie lesen sehr
schnell zugängliche informationen die
wir sehr sehr kritisch eltern müssen und
bewerten ist als wir werden ihnen
gefordert jetzt kann aber auf den
kollektoren irak anders sagen wir so
große geschichte ist es doch gerade
digitalisierung und in diese mediation
ist doch gut was kann man denn jetzt
gegen diesen berechtigten kritischen
einwand
so war erst kritische seite diese ganzen
informationsflut ja das kann man aber
die mit gegensätzen
[Musik]
also früher musste ich ihn über sie
geredet wenn ich das ganz einfach
da war ich abhängig davon dass die
bibliothek offen ist das buch erzählt
dass ich in nogales hat er wirbelt ex
auswahl zu kaufen wenn man die
kostenlose bekommen hat ich musste viel
zeit und auch räumliche distanz auf mich
nehmen und es wird alles viel länger als
umwege direkt abhängig
das heißt jemand kann auf irgendeinem
erteilt dieser welt zu pferde internet
hat kann es nicht generell sagen das ist
eine sehr witzige sachen und sie werden
hier ändert sich schon bestimmte
strukturen ich habe ich einen raum und
zeit sind so dass ich nicht ändern sich
im rahmen der digitalität unmittelbar
halbwegs punkten
und ich will komme dass sie in räume
bekomme sie auf meinem smartphone der
hosentasche und ich muss nicht mehr den
weg zurücklegen sind informationen
kommen noch nicht ich gehe jetzt hier
wichtig zusammen nur so kann durchbruch
gleich und letztes fiel um jene die
initiative
digitale welt online welchen entsprechen
unsere ganze die natürlichkeit zu bohren
und auch die funktionsweisen und
transistor und wir verstehen es endlich
in der lage alles zu verstehen was
passiert auch wenn es zu komplex und
herrsche
was jetzt in der natürlichen alles gut
also sie sagen kann wenn sie eltern eine
digitale welt und er ist zu sagen dass
die prinzipiell besteht weil analytisch
diskretion und 19 anderen dividieren
lässt und von uns auch erschaffen wurde
mir sind schon von dieser welt oder geht
es aber die richtige welt an diesem
gesagt oder natürliche welche die fragen
die sie machen wenn man dann sagen dass
es durch die wälder computer die
natürliche welt und die ist nicht uns
gemacht und dann können dann immer
weiter ins kleinste detail anschauen und
wenn wir immer weiter kleinteilen finden
sich gibt es dunkle materie und genauso
natürlich immer größer gg nicht micro
kosten makrokosmos finden wir weniger
aktien die sich unsichtbar erschließt
das ist klar - sehr wichtige differenz
was könnte man jetzt auf den
kommilitonen antwort wenn man jetzt die
digitale welt ein bisschen stärker
machen
[Musik]
menschen vermisst
einbußen von menschen geschaffen wird es
gibt zum beispiel aufstellen
zum beispiel wenn ein bisschen ist das
szenario den komplex durch den rücken
ergo es schaffen dass jeder versteht er
kommt also ist
befragt werden
die grundstruktur werden verstehen auch
eine verstehen dass intel auskommen und
auch die webseite kümmern
[Musik]
als semi kommt schneller seines sohns
stand ergeben dass zeitprobleme und über
komplexität ist wo ich verstanden dass
komplex sind um zu bewältigen ist kein
verfahren angehen und man könnte jetzt
natürlich denken oder vorstellen ins
spekulative dann ist ein bisschen
aufpassen ich konnte das ist sein können
dass irgendwann so komplexe neuronale
den centrica dass die selbst aus rom
während ich versuchte es ist möglich wir
wollen uns aber nicht groß aber es wäre
konzentrieren letzten ganz komplexe
fortsetzt und wir könnten vielleicht ein
so komplexes und alles erschaffen das
dicht gepackt ist viele verknüpfungen
hat was der löwen von autonomen wird und
gute ansätze etwas energien sondern im
ergänzt entsteht plötzlich etwas und
nehme ich gern in riesa will können sich
erkläre aus der welt auserwählt noch die
also das ist das stichwort die summe ist
das ganze ist mehr als die summe seiner
teile hatte entstehen zusatzeffekt der e
mail dienst können ich war aber das ist
jetzt ein bisschen strecken wieder tief
aber jetzt möchte ich ganz übersichtlich
für dich um diesen unterschied zum
analogen und digitalen zu verstehen als
chance dieses linke bild -zeitung - corp
und hier das wartestand sehr
kontinuierlich das heißt es gibt keine
brüche stetig und differenzierter mit
mathematischen wir können jeden punkt ab
line sind wir sind keine knicke und wir
könnten immer mehr ging somit belegen
immer weiter gesungen und wir werden
dieses kommt hier auf einen letzten
punkt so gekommen wie sonst gibt's
endlich ist das analoge signal dass
minute also unendlich die finanzierbares
auf ihr punkt die natürliche welt können
wir vielleicht so das ist jesus forum es
wurde jetzt als diese sinuskurve dieser
bogen im digital der brücke zu
beschreiben das ist passiert ist zerlegt
worden
einfach mal vom ersten bild licht
genau wir haben einzelne punkte wir
haben hier weil die ersten kunden im
rüstungs und haben wir den dritten punkt
den schrägen als wenn wir jetzt das
nachzeichnen würden jetzt mehr linie
also immer die mädchen würden würde man
muss gucken dass eine annäherung könnte
die jetzt aber nicht mehr kontinuierlich
diskret das heißt wir haben ist das was
die arbeiter teil wirkt glücklich sind
aber es in verschiedene einheiten
ja aber es ist nicht mehr differenziert
all diesen kleben ist nicht mehr die
veränderungen vollziehen
na dann kann man die steigung nicht
berechnen also steht die großen aber es
ließe sich auch bestimmten auslegen muss
nicht schlecht ist einfach das schild
die funktion und was ist jetzt
ja wir haben sie mit übersichtlichkeit
wir haben es einfach also auch nicht
einfach ein bisschen ohne es ist noch
ein weiter punkt hier dieses wertes
diskret wie verstehen sie das jetzt ist
krieg
wie kannst du es nur still
im gegensatz zur welt kommen würde ich
also sie haben recht richtig gesagt ist
es bestätigt ja es gibt nur einen
bereich nicht ausreichen werden diverse
funktionäre gegeben
das kriegen dafür bekannt
ja ich habe jetzt endlich qualifiziert
ich habe aus diesem endlosen
kommentieren um habe ich mir gewisse
blöcke aus die es annäherungsweise
abnehmen sollte einfach wissen wann
haben sie es uns noch anmelden
das nämliche kommt hier und wird endlich
gemacht dass im gehirn und qualifizierte
gekannt und verschiedene einheiten
zerlegt das ist zumindest ein punkt
fehlte mittagessen das ist natürlich
alles selbst informationen letztendlich
wird der ausblende aus nullen und einsen
das ist das lab e10 bikes muss denen
jeweils ein bisschen mehr besteht und
die spitze als die können sich dann zu
agieren zu einer geben sie drauf um
computer und dann bekommen sie dieses
ehemals analoge signal dieses in der
natur hören können bekommen sie dann
reproduziert das geht natürlich verlor
dabei geht es rüber
[Musik]
das wollen wir die möglichkeiten von 101
bekanntwerden formen oder eingesammelt
werden
es geht auf jeden fall auch information
verloren
diese ganzen stetigen undifferenziert
war und das ist entscheidend ganzen
liefern und ziel waren punkte gehen
wieder viele nicht alle beziehungsweise
sie wissen dass die mathematik
wir dürfen eine funktion so was wir
dürfen sie erfahren dass er gerade aber
es ist also sie ist an manchen stellen
ist sie gliedern sich aber nicht an
diesen klicken nicht das heißt gegen
formation verließen sie zum beispiel
anhören musikstück besonders gute
akustik bemängeln dass der bestimmte
frequenzen von rom gegangen einfach
umsatz konnte dagegen um 3 aber sind
über irgendwas vorgegangen sein
im vergleich zu natürlich sind immer
einbringen darf ließ und das ist
zurückzuführen auf diese eingehende
differenziertheit wir bekommen nicht
diese schöne kurs diese schöne natur
prof ihren containern gekommen wir
einfach die zahlen nur sehr schlecht
einfach anderes weichen recht analogie
denn es kam hinter spiele spielen
was fällt ihnen auf jetzt nicht wort
hier kästchen das passt nicht allen
die spieler stellen fest
genau genommen kranken gletscher
krankengeld von neuem 3d karten
geschaffen ist und wie sieht es aus
fernsten an den rändern zu vermeiden
aber es gegen die perfekt werden sie
noch mal genau hinschauen sagt mehr
auflösen
dieses bild dieses gerät hat eine
auflösung neuerdings 4k oder nimmt
marcel wie viel die fia hat sein gutes
konterspiel und afrikanische vier kabel
für kabelkunden also wir haben
angefangen 640 x 480 bildpunkte und ich
glaube der fernseher hat 56 84 und
führen die alte röhrenfernseher und und
ihre handys gleich eine auflösung von
30.000 mal 6 das heißt dass wirklich
bild wie wir jetzt jetzt hier sehen
das ist endlich mal aufgelöst alles ein
bild was in digitaler tief hinein zoomen
werden zulegen auf pixel stoßen und das
ist nicht anders als diese irgendwelche
diskreten fixen aber man kann das
natürlich wird auch nicht wirklich als
also das was du mit dem augen sehen
nicht als auflösung bezeichnen das ist
irgendwie sinnlos und dass man die
lassen unsere augen wenig rechten
verliehen hat kein auflösen keine tabus
es ist das funktioniert anders als sind
digitale
die gedanken nicht ratlos sind
ausschließlich so dass wir täglich im
code als service signale erhalten was
vom computer digital
wir fragen uns ob das generelle freundes
und der zweite habe
ansonsten verhält 200 computer sozusagen
der zugang verwehrt ist ist als das
andere signale erreichen
das ist ja auch gut wirkung das endlich
technische fragen und wenn sie irgendwas
über die durch nutzung des computers
bearbeiten
das bin dann müssen sie es notgedrungen
dermaßen die unserer jetzigen technik
digitalisieren
es gibt es nur ist nur ein stichwort
quantencomputer überlegung zu stellen
wenn ich nur 101 gebraucht sonst renomee
und das ist ganz schmalen wie es die das
daher entwickeln wird ob da nicht noch
die ganz neue dimensionen von
digitalisierung
das ist grundsätzlich mit unserer
jetzigen team muss alles diesen wegen
leben vom diskreten zum kontinuierlichen
und damit geht auch ein gewisser
[Musik]
super muss nicht also sie kennt man
diese schalter und diese alten schenker
und jetzt sagen viele mich
eingeschlossen
das den thron viel besser wissen müssen
qualität viel räumlich ist weil es eben
physisch dann abgenommen aber das ist
eben mit italien ist das sind jedem
vertiefungen die viel mehr noch der
mechanische geräusche der diskreten
mechau hier ist dieses eine echte vor
gericht
also mir scheint dass immer noch viel
mehr bezug zur natürlichen welt gegeben
ist bei solchen alten schellackplatten
alles nennt sie die tv sah man kann ich
morgen analog computer bauen und hat nur
dass ich zum beispiel sehr temperatur
wenn ich was den keks ist und haben wir
die losgröße das rechnen
also mit wir können in der sitzung noch
mal anrufen damit verschiedenen
rechnerarchitektur beschäftigen wenn wir
vom heutigen rechner ausgeben geht kein
weg an der digitalisierung vorbei und es
ist mein problem
ein problematisches aber wir wollen ja
nicht nur bei der digitalisierung stehen
bald sehen was wir eigentlich machen
wollen ist ja integrität
aber sie haben sich gemeldet also das
kann nur so zum groben verständnis das
ist natürlich vollständig aber wir haben
jetzt ein paar punkte gesehen dass es
geht einmal unsere einfachen aber wir
gewinnen damit jede menge geschichten
tali sierung ich darf sie erinnern an
diese ganzen medien freizeit werden
völlig verändert unser raume
zeitverständnis eine neue form an
das alles sind phänomene die mit der
technischen entwicklung in den reinen
technischen entwicklung einher gehen und
grinst interessieren vor allem die damit
einher geht um die würde ich jetzt noch
als digitalität sind also phänomene die
aufgelesen das technisch neue energie
daraus hervorgingen und die wie ich
finde so langsam aber sicher auch mal
klassifizieren müssen präsentieren nicht
nur regel scheint sich in verschiedenen
ansichten
ich möchte sie auf einen hinweis wenn
ich ziemlich interessant finde und zwar
heißt es die 50 wichtigsten themen der
digitalisierung und wenn ich dass es
gleich eine durchgehende übrigens
reinschauen
das ist ein ganzes steht dann sehen sie
also bits und bytes hardware netzwerk
internet weltweit weg cloud online
trends monetarisierung
internetfähig news rolle nsn
datenüberwachung das internet oft
ängstlich der ist virtual reality 3d
druck locker und bridgepoint künstliche
intelligenz ob sie kam aus rom und
sexualität aus dem es wagen genannt dass
die 40 vom homo sapiens zum mond - das
mädchen habe dieses modell
ich weiß aber durchgehend das sind ganz
präsentieren der die digitalisierung
betreffen aber ich finde in den bereich
der totalität die also häufig ihre für
gesundheit
ich habe mir erst mit bitcoins tun haben
mit digitalen bewegungen ganz verändert
das unser leben
das ist nicht nur einfach ein basta
entsteht sind das hat implikationen und
diese implikationen sind die kultur zu
leben aber vor einem augen geht es schon
in sich und in hamburg ist mit der frage
wie passt das eigentlich ein ding ist
das was ein kind ist eigentlich ein
programm
wir können sich anfassen das hat keine
ausbildung gastein und unlogisch hat
dieses ding dieses digitale
das sind ganz klar vor allem die taktik
die bloß die italien sind der technik
überschreiten diese ganz großen fragen
zu entgehen ist wo kann ich sehen will
weil sehr viele interessante ansätze
kann sie noch fragen zum digitalen um
die fans das ist wirklich sehr pauschal
jetzt erstmal ganz plakativ von mir sind
dargelegt als erster ein stück wir haben
sechs der sieben zuschauer kommentare
haben auch schon ein paar kilo cast an
bord und ist einmal selber mit es kommen
bestimmt
jetzt geht es nämlich wirklich ins thema
ein
und jetzt sage ich in kürze fragen in
diesem sinne an
das geschieht als ich möchte diesem
seminar hab folgendes diskutieren das
haben wir schon ein bisschen nach wie
verhalten sich die logik und kita alles
du tour so alles wir haben gesagt okay
quantifizierung das kontinuierliche
diskontierung es wird nicht mehr
passierbar es geht einfach mal zu
erfahren aber wir haben viele vorteile
geben sie doch einen anderen punkt
werden sie einmal einen ton oder ein
akustisches signal
das ist natürlich gegeben ist
digitalisiert was haben sie da mit dem
super gemacht den sie einmal an vogel
gesellschaft mit ihren rekorde mit dem
handy aufnehmen und speichern
3 was danach genau auswerten
für den service immer ist
offen aussprechen
genau zwischen ganz wichtigen punkt an
sie werden in der natur weil sie so
kontinuierlich ist sie richtig sagten
werden sie wahrscheinlich dass
identische phänomen
zweimal haben werden nun zwei mal genau
denselben stein haben sie werden je zwei
mal genau diesen vogel klar es geht
nicht und das wäre mich gesagt die
fernsehen ist weil es so differenziert
ist
sie haben eine so eindeutige nun die
individuelle singuläre natur linie ihren
ganz eigenen schaffen ein so
überbordenden reichtum informationen
dass sie wohl nie wieder zweimal
denselben bisher analog ereignis erhöhen
selbst wenn sie dieselbe schellackplatte
zweimal abspielen es wird nicht das
selbe selbe spezialisten natürlich trägt
ist auch gerne sagen wenn sozusagen
wiedersehen petri und abstieg ist auch
nicht dasselbe
klar weil neben die ausgangspunkte der
in eben dann letztendlich irgendwie
analog eigentlich mal diese ganze boxen
die dann anfangen zu vibrieren wir
wieder an
aber wenn sie mode derzeit nicht einmal
zu uns wert haben sie dann zweimal exakt
identischen soundsoviel kilobyte
wenn die 33 kilowatt nicht mehr nicht
weniger dann hat dies so viel
dann können sie wieder aufs
multiplizieren das heißt sie bekommen
eine ganz neue problematik identität
zwar die kommen hier sagen identitäten
sind kommen mehrere entitäten mehrere
dinge die genau wie dennis und es gibt
einen spruch von den philosophie bleiben
letzte gesagt hat wenn zwei dinge genau
identisch stimmt dann sind sie dass
andere sie und ich uns jetzt hat man
sich fragen ist es nicht paramenten sie
jetzt mit mir genau dasselbe programm
auf den apparaten haben wir nicht
mehrere instanzen des zeltes ist damit
eines wie ist die lage dieses dieser
datei zu stehen und was uns logisch ist
wie ist das zunächst verfasst so einiger
zeit
ich komme genau das versprechen aber
dahin dass ein paar mal sind uns selbst
mal auf die these dann wäre das also
mein digitales wiederholbarkeit bedeutet
und ja klar dass dann kontinuierlich
kite sondern natürlich kein einmaligkeit
der singularität als die natur scheint
mir nicht reproduzierbar zu sein
im auch im stil der strikte numerischen
städtischen dasselbe genau das was den
einem anderen identisch ist nicht nur
ein ähnliches interesse
[Musik]
die bakterien ebenfalls die bären an
soll in der regel schneller sie andere
kommissare moleküle wendepunkt in der
information genommen dass das könnte
wenn die information ganz klar
darzulegen ist daher geht es schon
dieselbe genommen also wir sehen da gibt
es schon die natur so ein bisschen
ähnliche punkte aber es gibt jedenfalls
naturphänomene die ebenso differenziert
sind also nicht sagen dass er nicht
bekommt und im digital gibt es jetzt
betreut und solche modernen waren ja
auch sicherstellen möchte dass ihnen
diversität gibt das künstlich liebenthal
diversität erzeugen
sie sehen wir kommen plötzlichen
logischen und logisch fragen definitiv
sagen wir wenn wir einmal ein signal
digitalisiertes ausbildung und wir haben
wegen abdruck das ist das problem
solch ein heikles ökumenisch gestohlen
es reicht dass da ein politiker eine
dickere fünf minuten lang etwas für zehn
sekunden dass der inhalt des dokuments
auf dem tisch liegen lässt dann komisch
vorbei mit meinem smartphone die camps
kenner und klicke eines comics und ich
habe es doch mein gutes gefühl
ich klicke aufteilen und ich und alle
meine freunde und die verstehen es sind
alle hier ist in zehn minuten ist das
ding um die ganze welt und deshalb will
ich leben
wir müssen dieses in bremen die
musiktitel sie mussten sich mit dem
fotografen schwieriges merken was
draufstand müssen 7 erzählen und in
kansas ist ein problem der flüsterpost
als er gegen hollmann und das ist
eigentlich der konzeption was können wir
ein system veränderung das ist
jedenfalls beim digital nicht erfahrung
das heißt das ist erst mal als solches
unter seine phänomen aber sie werden
damit die ethische und ökologische
logische frage stimmen notwendig mit
einigen
dieses phänomen ist im irak also das ist
das problem in welchem verhältnis stehen
die phänomene der digitalisierung
digitalität dem club eingegangen sind
hat mit diesem namen von kollegah
zierten gefallen dass man die metaebene
ist das ist als eine revolution ist und
dann inwiefern konstruiert dass wir eine
digitalität eine eine kultur die von der
analogen qualitativ erschienen ist
die kulturen sind gespielt den wir das
jetzt hier gerade live auf youtube
übrigens 310 zuschauer es geht hoch sie
sehen kommentare als zuschauer
das ist eine kultur herr sich facebook
kultur diesmal die leicht gemacht die
ist immer ambivalent also als wenn es zb
auf facebook ist die möglichkeiten
daumen nach unten
sie machen jahrhundert geht bei youtube
aber sie sehen neben digitalen die
digitale kommunikation der daumen nach
oben ermöglichen lässt dann bleiben
viele sache gestellt und nicht die
kritik kritik wirklich eine richtig das
problem
ich werde sie zur seite ich wollte nur
sagen sie kommen ganz neue
kommunikationsformen spiel gegen die
neue kultur aus dass das spiel die ganze
gaming kunst kultur die ganzen
computerspiele
wir kommen darauf auch noch mal genauer
sprechen ich spiele habe ja auch sehr
gerne aber dass das kürzlich werden
einige kultur wenn sie sehen wie spiele
programmiert sind die spiele in falten
eine ganz eigene geschichte
es haben artikel jüngste werde ich ihnen
mal zugänglich machen die sagt das sagte
ich glaube derzeit stand ist dass die
neuen romane und die neuen großen
geschichten dass die nicht nur in
büchern geschrieben werden nicht mehr
filmen zum kinderspiel
da ist was dran und zwar deswegen weil
wenn ich nur passive zuschauer sind es
oft ein riesen lassen sondern selbst
aktiv sind die geschichten und häufig
auch verschiedene möglichkeiten haben
die geschichte beeinflusst selbst ein
aktuell sind kommt dann gibt es das
phänomen der avatare der christlichen
identität die man sich dazu legt
digitalen identitäten also jetzt muss
ich interessante kulturelle für meine
die wir mal reflektieren müssen
außerdem so verstehen sie es soll eines
der ziele dieses seminars gibt es weiß
wie eine digitale die kommilitonen hat
er gesagt
gemälde die bezahle welt verstanden
hatte
also viele gründe sowie digitale welt
gibt es nicht es gibt noch eine welt und
es ist die welt in der wir hier alle
hierfür zu schätzen und das ok das ist
eine these aber man kann sich fragen
entwickelt nicht dieses ganze
digitalisierte eine eigendynamik eigene
kausalität also ich glaube dass man sich
orientieren immer dadurch bestimmen kann
wenn man zeigt dass daraus keine alle
kräfte herford haben sie demnächst eine
basis die welt wichtig ist wie wir
scheint entwickeln digitale phänomene
causa liegt die interessanten davon aus
digitale werbung mit denen wir bezahlen
computerspiele in denen selbst werte
generiert werden also fähigkeiten die
bezüglich computerspielen geschätzten
und kann dieses spiel sind das ist ihre
kampfkunst eine sportart immer der
natürlichen verlage wie mehr scheint
haben dass hier tatsächlich in einigen
realität zu tun hat digitalen identität
der digitalität nennen kann
ich glaube nicht dass sie sich
reduzieren ist auf die natürlich glaube
dass mir eigene welt bedeuten darüber
kann man diskutieren das kann man
streiten machen wir kurzumfrage eine
nummer merken wer glaubt dass es eine
kita
ich glaube dass sie nicht glauben würde
in ordnung das soll die hauptfrage seit
diesem jahr gibt es eine digitale bild
gibt es nicht
wenn es eine digitale gibt dann muss sie
an ökonomischen status angezeigt 1 1
hilft es da zu sein
wir müssen zu erkennen können und wir
müssen zeigen dass über kausale kräfte
dass der kausalität des spieles die sie
nicht reduzieren ist auch die
natürlichen und ist also eine eigene
kausale mächtigkeit daran wird es hängen
ob wir diese kausalität und erklärt wenn
wir das können dann glaube ich eine gute
gründe dafür werden der digitale welt
als wir müssen natürlich seien diese
digitale welt genauer bestimmen und zwar
auf aber mit zwei kategorien
immanuel kant hat seine philosophie die
kredite ein fünfter ganz wesentlichen
abgehoben oder frau gezeigt als digitale
als reine anschauen
unsere erkenntnisse also es sind es
jetzt grund dazu
ohne diese überhaupt nicht erkennen
können und auch nicht existieren können
und jetzt müssen wir schauen ob sich
diese halten alle chancen bei kant nicht
nur bekannt über alle rauen zeiten halt
größten erfahrungen innerhalb derer sich
den astra spielen und die sich bei der
digitalwelt soll sie denn gibt ändern
die frage meine vermutung ich genau
nicht ganz am ende
einfach nur die zeit wird ungefähr bei
der digitalen werden wird sind nämlich
sein
es sind vielleicht beschleunigungsphasen
beben das wird vielleicht ein bisschen
flugtiere dort sei die zeit wird
vielleicht ja ich glaube sie nur zehn
kollegen jährlich was ich glaube was ich
von einem ist der raum versteckt das ist
einfach distanzen keine rolle mehr
vermittelbar
ich glaube die digitale welt natürlichen
andrologen des raumes als die natürliche
welt
es gibt kein ausgedehnt und geräumig
großen geben digitales ausgegeben
dateien haben einen seitlichen prozess
wenn ich dateien ausführen auch diese
zeit einfach zu spielen aber ich glaube
wir haben sie in ihrem logischen
redaktion ist um als im teuren ich
glaube am raum wird sich einiges ändern
in der digitalen welt darüber müssen wir
noch mal diskutieren welche da haben uns
schon angesprochen welche räumlichen
zeitlichen logik dem film gibt eine
kriegsgründe ich glaube eben dass die
raum logik sich etwas ändern wird die
zeit dass er mal ein punkt ist nicht
lästig und sie denken digitalisiert und
den künstlichen klicken zu mir ja jetzt
geht es also zu aktiver können sich die
grenzen ist also ist unser denken gerade
so komplex und so kontinuierlich und so
differenziert dass wir es gar nicht
digital abbilden können dass sie es gar
nicht künstlich entlassung
das entspannende verhalten wir wollen da
nicht nur spekulieren so wollen es
wirklich wir wurde aufgrund geht also
gewesen und war mit neuronalen netzen
geschafft beschäftigt wir werden da eine
sitzung haben wir die scan bleiben hier
gemeinsam prosa unseres netzwerks und
jetzt denke diese grundlagen verstanden
haben können wir auch wirklich für das
so fischer wer aussagen über diese
möglichkeit treffen müssen das alles
fungieren durch durch wir sind das jetzt
ist und schließlich eine frage welche
systemische und ästhetisch bedeutet
erkenntnistheoretische und seines mäßig
ok also dass das ist immer etwas tee
mischen erkenntnistheorie wie kann ich
erkennen kann ich mit der bahn werden
und des bewusstseins mäßig da passt in
seiner existenz wie existiert eine datei
unterschrieb zahnstein unterliegt
existierte dabei überhaupt die leute die
sagen es gibt nur die die natürliche
welt aber sie würden wahrscheinlich
fragen müssen dateien existieren nicht
es gibt keine dinge die dateien sind -
so robusten wortspielereien müssten die
leute für die zeiten müssen wir haben
auch ideen gedanken träume ja auch nicht
nicht hat sich unter fragen oder
wie steht es in die leben vorstellung
richtig genau gesehen recht in unserem
gehirn verstanden dass da auch nicht
anders sagen dass es physisch ist mein
manche würden sagen ist anderes hc
reduktion leisten würden sagen unsere
gedanken sind lose phänomen perfekte
unser gehirn verteilt sind los
wie wenn ich ebenso als nicht sexy
phänomen als wie wenn ich jetzt
dokumentiert bei ganz setzte man kommt
dann auch aus dieser dampf der daraus
kommt er spielt keine kausale rolle mehr
es ging nie wieder mal um kausalität
phänomen bedeutet da entsteht etwas was
aber causales relevant ist und jetzt
würden sie wahrscheinlich sagen dass uns
gehen das sehr vorsichtig dass das sehr
wohl kaum bekannt ist
wenn ich jetzt die idee habe wie es sein
könnte dass die digitale welt ist ist
man dann hat dies eine karosserie kraft
unter umständen weil ich nehme ich dann
anfange buch zu schreiben und ein
solches haus gehen und ich kann nur
schlecht erklären warum ich jetzt
wenn ich das nur aus dem verschaltungen
man kann die leute gehen sagt die
tatsache dass wir jetzt sitzen über die
lokalisierung digitalität regen lässt
sich total der zurückführt auch unsere
verschuldung es diesen zustand dieser
ließen dann würde ich sagen ja das ist
doch nicht erklärung dafür
ich meine es ist natürlicher basis aber
man kann nämlich erklären wie diese
gedanken erst digitalisierung ist wie
der jetzt verstanden werden kann wenn
man mir ganz im schnitt man es ernst da
werde nicht ganz aus ich sehe dass
mobilität und metallisierung entscheiden
eigene realität darzustellen
und jetzt scheint wir können unter
diskutieren das alles im griff schon an
mit ideen gedanken mit unserem willen
der vielleicht etwas da stimmt was nicht
rein werden und materialistisch wir sind
ja natürlich in welcher stadt
wenn wir in allen erkannt folgen haben
wir auch weiter viel vernunft bilder das
wissen der angeborenen fähigkeiten auch
möglichkeit sollte das volk
aufzustacheln
das unterscheidet sich ja ganz schnell
zum nächsten verwandten seien so griff
man anfassen kann ich die auch oder
punkt also kann ich wie sie richtig
sagen würde sagen dass alle lebewesen
aus den menschen und ausländischen dass
die neben letztendlich eigentlich nur
natürliche wesen zu noch extrem hat es
wenn ihr den karts getan
wir kennen sie alle diesen großen häuser
suchen
er hat gesagt alle tiere sind nicht nur
lose natürlichen lebewesen zumindest im
plus maschinen als er hat alle tiere die
nicht möchten menschen auch nicht
bezeichnen was viele
naturwissenschaftler tun
alle tiere sind wirklich nur analoge
maschine sozialen rede gewesen und des
tanzes kitas und diese denken dass tanzt
ist eben nicht mechanisch zu verfassen
es ist eine eigene realität das ist
sontra listen das wir bekommen
symbolismus und es ist gut als darauf
hinweisen wir haben diesen dualismus
eigentlich schon uns als die touristen
wir haben ja schon einen gewissen
dualismus werbeideen wir haben gedanken
wie es nicht eindeutig auf das
materielle reduzieren lassen scheinen
und damit hat er mir in verbindung zu
der digitalität die ja auch nichts ist
was ich rein mechanische verstehen uns
das heißt wir hätten so einschlägt
bereits unser puzzle gemacht und dann
gibt es eine gewisse nähe stichwort
neuronales netzwerk ist halt hier sind
der punkt wo wir eventuell des übergangs
unserem denken hinzu der digitalen welt
angekommen
deswegen ist mir ganz wichtig auf diese
neuronalen netzwerk einzugehen
es ist ganz leicht zu sagen der
unterricht zu programmieren
kein zweifel diese und auch in python
cancer flow kennen sie
es gibt ganz viele ganz einfache
bibliotheken von peißen und dieser
programmiersprache wie man also wirklich
in ganz wenigen schritten sondern machen
wir heute ist in ansätzen macht wenn es
jemand verstehen da sind wie sony liegt
also grundsätzlich fragen wie fett ist
dass wir in der digitalität
philosophische relevant und welche
logischen ökologischen publikationen hat
das findet das sind so die wichtigsten
fragen die wir uns hier und jetzt muss
ich dich ein bisschen näher darauf
eingehen auf die einzelnen themen die
wir jetzt in seminaren machen haben aber
wir sagen auch sagen was nicht geht ich
dann die displays soll
willst du ein bisschen polemisch nicht
wollen wir zukunft spekulationen
das hat uns schwer fallen immer
herausschauen müssen könnte wir wurden
nicht von irgendwas leben wenn ich
irgendwie die technischen grundlagen die
basis verstanden wir müssen alles wieder
so machen etwas reden wäre spekulation
ist nicht unser geschäft und wir wollen
auch keine zeit also könnte sein und
wirklich nicht machen also wir können
natürlich belegen was könnte sein aber
müssen es begründen wir müssen den logos
spiegel regieren als im krieg sich
zukunfts ereignis die das sein könnten
oder wahrscheinlich sind zu uns geht um
logisch implikationen von strukturen die
menschen verstehen können wir müssen
also diese logischen strukturen weiter
denn etwas anderes als nicht mit einer
zukunftsprognose
die wollen logischen reduzieren
logischen müssen argumente geben dafür
dass wir diese auffassung vertreten
könnten das jetzt in 50 jahren was
passiert müssen wir doch die basieren
auf gewissen strukturen die wir jetzt
schon einsehen können deshalb also
unsere methode ist wird auch ein
bisschen zug und die spekulationen seien
sie begründen so leichter verlust ich
muss ein bisschen mehr gas geben
digitalität hat einfach diesen themen
des seminars
schaut man genau hin jetzt wirklich
spannend jetzt geht es um die themen
dieses jahr mit alle verdienen demnach
bekommen haben ist nicht schlimm weil ja
auch die welt das finden sein wird auch
immer eine art riesen fast hätte mir das
auch noch genau
also um was geht es jetzt hier
heute haben wir mal so ein bisschen
diese analog digital die verbände
behandelt
das ist im grund und der schaltung wir
können uns aber auch unbedingt notwendig
sein muss man um über unser thema zu
sprechen
wir reden jetzt von digitalität
vitalisierung müssen es wird immer so
die abgrenzung des volkes sein dass
analog und wie sie sagen wir könnten
[Musik]
dann von den zahnrädern grund nicht
sagen das ist die natürliche welt ist
sondern dass es die künstliche welt ist
sind stichworte die natur habe ich schon
mal gehört zeichnung tun als die erste
natur ist die natürliche welt die da
wächst und gedeiht
die vorfälle sind die biologisch ist ja
auch physikalisch und chemisch
beschreiben die zwei kulturen und es ist
die welt wo die kultur auftritt hat sie
menschen günstig sich tempel bauen
tempel blauen oder wo sie plötzlich an
hervorragenden steinzeitmenschen eine
flöte zu schnitzen auch musik oder brust
vielleicht weil ihren verstorbenen ist
die zweite kultur und jetzt ist leider
gibt es auch eine dritte nannte die fina
die die zahl reden nämlich ganze zeiten
und das ist die technologie die
technologie besitzen jetzt die frage
die digitalisierung wäre sicherlich die
2 ich will jetzt nicht zu viel in der
natur postulieren
aber ich glaube es gibt gewisse gründe
dafür so was mit getreten natur noch an
hinzunehmen
als sie von der zeit natur in ganz
entscheidende hinsicht verschieden und
das hat auch diese frage dieses
nach sein gibt es zwar interessiert oder
das ist die alternative für diese ganze
digitalisierungs geschichte gleich die
digitalität alle zu zeigen deshalb mit
fortsetzung diese zahl macht der marcel
ist sehr schön bezeichnen wenn wir noch
jemanden im sommer oder wir das
übermorgen meinst du das einfach
kontierung derzeit tun ist die zweite
natur alles was der mensch geschaffen
hat kultur menschliche leistung also
wenn ich jetzt gesammelt und essen und
das kochen ist es dann aufzeichnen wenn
man es kocht schon bei dem sammeln wird
also oder punkte ich glaube dass bei
menschen alles fast alles zweite natur
ist
ich glaube der menschen ganz seltener
formung der nur ersten unschuld selbst
das essen wo man sagen würde nahrungs
zuwanderung einfache tiere überhaupt
nicht das ist da bliebe halten ist auch
genau die will 1 auch gekommen ist und
wenn wir werden wir uns zu ernähren mit
ihr und wir kommen probleme organisch
schon mehr wissen
er ist unseren verdauungstrakt auch
nicht eingestellt bismarck mal der frei
gewesen sein dass unsere vorfahren ich
weiß es nicht verdient 1000 jahre wo es
gleich verkraftet haben das haben sie
verkraftet
aber da ist eben nicht kulturell fallen
also man muss immer schauen was machen
die erste tour ich glaube es gibt fast
alles einfiel es gibt fast keinen
einzigen bereich also im leben der nicht
kulturell reformation ihr zweiter
selbst frau pflanzen und alle diese
dinge die man normalerweise nur als
biologischen prozess erstellt das
inzwischen ist sie
beim sammeln nachdem zeitung natur zu
gehen etwa so aus spaß das sagen sondern
zum raten der diode bruder punkte gut
der dann die zweite natur sehr glücklich
würde sagen wir müssen dann immer so ein
bisschen zur natur auch zu sprechen
werden aber sie lernschwierigkeiten
seminar mal gegeben mit dem titel der
geister tiere und also ich bin dafür
offen diesen diesen übergang von erst am
zweiten tour fließen zu haben wie zum
beispiel glaube ich dass was ist im
tennis den informationen verbunden
für ihren tieren zu eignen ist
letztendlich läuft alles auf den begriff
der freiheit aus
der rabe ist freier sich gedanken zu
machen wie er sein futter am besten
bekommt dann muss es nicht so eben von
natur leben ist er kann flexibel damit
und ich glaube die zweite natur zeigt
ist an dieser flexibilität und über der
ersten idee kommt ohne wahnsinn sagte
die männer lieben unternehmen auf die
erste tour
und genau so könnte die digitalität eine
höhere potenz jackson auf die
zeichnungssumme von einem und dem raben
wird in ansätzen schöne zeit es gibt
auch andere tiere definitiv gewisse
verbünde haben dieses
gesellschafterstrukturen bin ich einfach
nur trieb mäßig gesteuert sind soll man
sagen da hat sich jemand gedanken und da
kommt nach meinen begriffen und auch
nach dem für die zeichner tour spielen
jetzt sagen sie sich mit zweite natur
zumindest für die nämlich die mädchen
auch verändert hat sich organisch genau
seine funktionen weiter genau das ist ne
wechselwirkungen sowie in dem uns
register sie den rhein gibt
berlin die zweite tour aus denen das ist
xamax an und der herzliche menschen die
gebiete die nach wären tragen ja wir
haben unser fehlen bis zum ende
sie müssen uns kleidung anziehen
das ist für mich außer dem begriff der
zweite überhaupt kalten temperaturen
erlebt dafür brauchen wir das nicht vor
wie viele millionen jahre und empfehlen
das alles natur
aber jetzt hat sich das geändert jetzt
wird mir mensch also das ist wenn ich so
ein punkte
dafür schicken ich möchte alles
problematisch startet und bitte sie
dafür alles im irak problem an die sie
jederzeit wenn ich sie zum beispiel dran
nehmen
schreiben sie nehmen einfach hier
kommentar die sich hier und dann werde
ich darauf eingehen also könnte es gerne
jetzt schon machen was rein schreiben
chatten komme ich darauf zu sprechen so
das ist also mit der digitalisierung die
parität ich habe schon ein paar gute
angerissen was die information ist ein
ganz wichtiges information die die frage
gehört der information ist ungefähr
genauso zentral wie die frage nach dem
verhältnis von digitalen gelobt es geht
letztendlich um unterschiedliche formen
von informationen
lange schon mal so ein bisschen
eine form der information dass diskret
sie finanzierbar
jeder punkt und die andere form des
bekannten zeit und verschiedenen
formationen
wir haben glaube ich mich in der
anwesenheitslisten leder nach einem
format mit dir einfach mal aufzeigen
wunderbar das heißt sie sind da
kompetenter als ich bin da kein experte
aber ich denke man kann ist auf
informationen zurück bringen zu dürfen
wir gerne jederzeit gestattet
die der information wir müssen stimmen
war vor 19 110 zuschauern wieder sehr
gut wir steigen
neuronale netzwerke mein lieblingsthema
glaube dass die zukunft
jetzt reden über zukunft darf ich
eigentlich nicht wenn ich über zu
empfehlen sich sofort zurecht reisen
wir wollen immer zu gesprächen gegeben
haben aber ich glaube dass das das
größte potenzial hat
also da ist viel potenzial teilen und
eine zwecke und wir wollen hier in einer
sitzung also ein bisschen diese struktur
eines neuen ein letzter zeit dass sie
mal die grundstruktur verstehen dann
können sie intelligenz und losfahren das
geht mit den roma
hier das ist zukunftsmusik das
hammerstatt wir müssen uns fragen
aufgrund der bestehenden strukturen auf
und dieser ist realistisch ist
anzunehmen dass dort mal wirklich ein
autonomes objekt entstehen kann das auch
frei ist darauf wird alles in der
familie im rahmen der digitalität freie
selbstbestimmte wesen erschaffen oder
können sie sich selbst waschen
stichwort frankenstein das ist wieder
ein bisschen alter topos der künstlichen
mensch aber wir sagen wenn wir diese
einheit zu betrachten
das soll eine frage sein ist prinzipiell
möglich und das ist eine unentschiedene
frage wie ist diese freiheit aussieht
lässt sich freiheit wirklich kürzlich
erschaffen oder müssen wir nicht mehr
geben aber aus dieser ersten hat schon
ganz schmale frage philosophie des
internets auch eines meiner
lieblingsthemen
ich finde das internet besonders
interessant und ich bin jetzt auch
philosophisch und zwar deswegen weil das
internet eben ein ganz wie der name
schon sagt ein ganz dichtes gewebe ist
das internet wo vielleicht sogar eine
eigene realität waren die durch ganz
enge bezüge kannst hier ist alles
miteinander in verbindung stehen
das ist ein ganz komplexes netz und ich
glaube dass das internet eine eigene
unschuld eines staates dann müssen sie
und energie des internets bestimmt damit
geht einher eben wie die formation
schaffen die hier im internet als
individuum und einbinden und auch welche
probleme damit verbunden was ist
virtualität ansprache dass dinge ankommt
und kollegen wiesen jörg an der gesagt
du musst ja auch das thema wird qualität
werden
das ist ein wichtiger punkt der
brutalität ist gar nicht so klar
virtuellen welt wünschen und mit ihm
wir müssen uns fragen sind wir schon wir
allerdings nicht denn noch realität und
ich glaube schon
ist das überhaupt der begriff den
virtuellen angemessen wenn wir sagen und
eine künstliche welt ist eine welt aber
das kann sich ändern lassen
also virtualität diesen begriff da immer
mehr im kommen ist wir wollen uns mit
diesen begriffen auch mal genauer
beschäftigen dann auch eines mit extra
themen und jetzt hoffe ich dass die
zuschauerzahlen ein bisschen weiter nach
oben schnellt jetzt geht es um ästhetik
digitalität version und computerspiele
wie ich schon sagte glaube ich dass das
computerspiel und als genoss als
kulturform nicht unterschätzen wird ich
glaube dass da die zukunft gelegt
auch der unterhaltung auch der ästhetik
und zwar nicht allein deswegen weil die
grafische qualität der massen sich
verbessert hat das unglaublich es ist
eingefangen hat nicht mal mit computern
das war so mitte der 90er jahren 697
habe ich angefangen in der warten die
bildschirmauflösung immerhin von 1024 x
das war schon ganz ok die spiele wenn
sie drei waren tauchte mantra den
beschleuniger stichwort q1 traffics sagt
das ist so eine sache
dann merkte ich dass die relation sehen
heute schneider von geforce gtx 1070
oder 2080 die grafiken damals waren klar
als solche erkenntlich dass computer
kaufen sind wenn sie heutzutage kommt
und spielen wieder anrühren 4 engine
glaube ich dann ist das teilweise
fotorealistischen sie nicht ganz genau
hinschauen wie kann ich mich ganz gut
aber es ist da ist es fast food willst
ich sie könnten ihn los und das ist doch
nix thema forschen und ich sehe wenig
bereich wo die digitalisierung braucht
digitalität so vorangetrieben wird wie
bei computerspielen sie auch daran dass
die neuen rechner die neuigkeit
gleichschritt mit den spielen schreiben
also wenn ein neues computerspiel
auskommt merken hocker die alten
grafikkarten tuns nicht mehr los in
einer grafik genau zurück es ist so ein
anderer
ich glaube dass wir auf die
computerspiele ganz besonderes auge
werfen müssen 30 irgendwie der weg weise
sind es da ist eskalationspotenzial
besonders zum teil unter stehen wir
schon in version ist ein wichtiger
begriff version in version also dass es
praktisch das aufgesogen werden diese
digitale struktur also sie die digitale
welt gehen sie haben legen sich aber
dazu kommen eine spielfigur und sie
übernehmen der antrag tätig schaffen
sich eine identität
und ich war wie handys internet mit
ihrer eigentlichen internet gibt es noch
unterschiede
sie erleben abenteuer sie reagieren
kausal wirksamen dieser welt sie können
vielleicht irgendwann diese wäre gar
nicht mehr unterschreiben
vielleicht die frage ist was hier
technisch möglich ist wir haben jetzt
diese neue 3d brille die auktions rift
kennen sie diese wirklich wo man nicht
auch bildschirm chance geben ist das ist
für mich sehr spannend und immer wieder
digitalität habe ich angesprochen also
welche ökonomischen status haben für
jene die der welt so es sie denn gibt
datei benötigte digitalität wir müssen
wir uns verhalten und dieser digitalen
welt so wie sie ihn gibt gelten dort
andere motive regeln als riesigen wert
man kann zumindest folgendes sagen die
erste natur ein gesetz das das natur
sagt die man kann das gesetz der
ursachen geben
das ist einfach nur wie die natur sich
leben so könnte auch sagen das ist das
gesetz der produktions team der stärkere
überlebt sie ganz plakativ gesagt jetzt
einfach dass natur kaum saale wird in
der natur kraft um sich das gesehen ist
der erste das gesetz ist in zwei schulen
würde ich sagen ist das gesetz dem rad
natürlich kann jetzt sagen moral hat
keine umgehend geltung versteht ihre
kulturen könnten zu unterschiedlich
man kann man sich mal einen anderen
morales gab meine moral das muss er
selbst aber dass überhaupt so was sie
gebracht aufzeigt dass wir es hier mit
einer anderen gesetzlichkeit als
logistiker jetzt kann man sich fragen
gibt es wenn die hand noch mal andere
gesetzt ist und dann gibt es neue
verhaltensweisen die wir beherzigen
müssen um ordentliche dieser digitalen
welt zu resident gibt existiert ich
denke hier muss man einiges reflektiert
werden hier ist noch einige dinge nicht
absehbar
und darüber freuen wir uns auch gedanken
das setzt natürlich voraus dass wir über
dem unternehmerischen status der
digitalität und schon einige gedanken
gemacht
erst auf dieser basis werden diese
fragen sind und ich zum schluss nicht
zuletzt die kultur der digitalität also
ja das ist eigentlich das ganze was
schlimmer machen
in büchern entwickeln sich digitale
produktion ich glaube das sehen sie
jetzt schon ab gibt es ganz viele mengen
an beispiel in zwei spielen
computerspiele
ich glaube auch dass die ganz gedeckt
die ganze pädagogik durch die
digitalisierung extrem impulse erfahren
wird wird gleich nochmal so zusammen ich
auch organisierten tagung die auch diese
frage wird so haben sie noch fragen ist
diesem seminar auch klar dass zum inhalt
nichts sagen
nicht vielleicht noch raum finden um
nicht nur den rücken sondern gut oder
punkt das soll sich dann auch als neuen
punkt auf nehme mich nur kultur der
digitalität diesen politik politik dann
fehlt ja oder botschaften
warum reden wir beeinflussen unser
jetziges gut macht er nichts zumal mit
punkt auf schreibst du einfach mal rein
ins kommentar dann sind es noch dass das
noch festgehalten wird also ungültig
politik der digitalisierung und was
erleben
dieser mann verliebt und das der kultur
ja auch die digitalisierung beeinflusst
genau diese wechselverhältnis aber die
zeit kommt ich werde es mir merken und
jetzt habe ich noch nicht gute
viertelstunde und jetzt falls keine
weiteren vorhang zum inhalt sind wie
gesagt es ist alles weg 7 als wenn sie
neue vorschläge haben können sich
jederzeit einbringen
idealerweise im chat ich sag gleich noch
was dazu ok alles laden gehen wir jetzt
zum technischen bern
hier ist die tagung was ist die
totalität pädagogische perspektiven am
28 29
juni 2010 in der heutigen straße 67 als
jener der gut ist aber bei der
politikwissenschaften der tugend
heimische garten
aber es ist schon höher sein und sie
finden das krank und die adresse
digitalität in vor und sie können sie
noch bis 22
das sind herzlich eingeladen ich würde
ihn auch wird sie bitten wir dann auch
in einer der sitzungen eben darauf
eingehen
sie finden da auch schon videos von
einigen der referentin referenten die
schon ein bisschen was erzählen über ihr
über die vortragsthemen ein bisschen die
didaktischen
diese qualität gehen sind sie herzlich
eingeladen und jetzt sage ich noch was
zumindest heute also texte lesen ich
werde auch wenn jeder sitzung text
hinzubekommen lassen
texte lesen probleme diskutieren aber
von beispielen neuen technik als gut ist
auch wenn man konkrete punkte reduzieren
und die vitalität und dauer dieses genau
dieses coups in der masse hat
eingeschrieben du hast als politiker
digitalisierung zweitens
wechselverhältnis von kulturen die
vitalität sind ihnen kriterien auf die
wir dank unserer teilnehmer eine
entscheidung in diesem jahr angehen
werden und wir mehr traditionell dem tal
vor sich gehen sehen wir hier schon
physische präsenz wäre schön wenn es
erregt wenn sich auch physisch präsent
werden und sie dürfen natürlich auch
digital das ganze transponieren sprich
sich einloggen
hier sehe ich jetzt in kommentaren
chefin
und sie dürfen gerne hier einfach
mitmachen darf mitmachen digital und
physisch stimmen online diskussion also
ich freue mich dann wirklich wenn sich
ja sogar noch ein bisschen mehr input
geben auch digital
damit ist authentisch wird sie bekommen
welche nicht zusammenfassung von mir per
email
ich habe nämlich ihre ganze
e-mail-adressen weist das system erde
führen
und ich habe jetzt schon vorweg es gibt
also keinen digitalität zimmer ohne da
er und ich sage dazu und es gibt jetzt
immer um 14 15 uhr raum 214 verdienen
die sich anmelden um einfach ganz locker
mal ein bisschen darüber mehr
diskutieren wurde marcel der tutorials
konnten wir euch anmelden
also wer mehr kann jetzt kommen die
haben es am 14
das ist mein büro und haben wir viele
stühle also wenn ihr nicht alle kommen
mit gegen alle und aber kommen sie
einfach wir schauen mal wichtig ist ja
ja das ist eine übung das ist eine übung
die findet jedes mal stehen also wir
leben da einfach mal ein bisschen wir
können auch so was wie hause aber als
thema anschnitt jetzt hier vieles habe
ich mir vorgenommen alle abonnieren
damals hatten wir nur 55 abonnenten
jetzt haben wir fast 57 also wollen so
die tausender marke knacken und so
großes ziel haben auch einige videos
drauf schauen sie mal durch wirklich
ganz verschiedenen marcel habe ich
einige gedreht und auch die ganzen
auszeichnung die sie jetzt hier sehen
während der alle angepasst wird
so viel locker ist etwa wenn sie im
smartphone haben können sich unter
nämlich sich hier aus
schon mittags los geht und sie sehen
hier die versteht den sinn
menü sehen wir schon sehen sich also
können sie sich wenn sie hier
draufklicken bekommen sie alle punkte zu
diesem seminar gewesen
und wenn sie dann das normale menü sich
anschauen können blau ist unser
kontaktiert seminar ich bin ein
antragsverfahren es um moral spitze
droht deswegen dann alle zusammen fast
so fehlten sie dann in der app auch
können sich direkt aus der app anschauen
und sie finden dort auch alle wichtigen
begriffe verlinkt und einem wiki system
also schauen sich ein angelangt ist und
hat schon eingeladen
machen sie es einfach funktioniert sie
ja genau also ich würde sagen bei sie
haben dann wirklich die richtige
vernetzung im sinne unseres seminars so
normal ist jetzt müssen wir mal dass
kurzer zu hause arbeiten als angie angie
shinehouse enthalten
und jemand der lehrerin studiert okay
das ist kriminell noch klären
als sie können die sache festlegen ich
würde wirklich raten belegen sind das
mit mir fest diese die systeme
[Musik]
machen sie das rechtzeitig das thema ich
werde noch eine liste zugänglich machen
25.000 zeigen solle die pausen und am
letztmöglichen abgabetermin ist der 23
september wieder nach mail können es um
die schippe nehmen
soviel zum thema bieten so die ganzen
physischen exemplare die formation
an digitalen werden alles schöne sprache
auf meiner festplatte also schicken sie
mir das e mail pdf-dokument stichwort
hausarbeit digitalität wenn sie krank
seien zeugen müssen sie ein attest vor
dem richtig times new roman schriftgröße
die ganzen formalitäten stelle ich
nochmals internet können sich nochmals
alles springen gründlich bitter so und
bitte komme hass von bestimmten wörtern
sätzen von konjunktion ganz wichtig
werden dieselben gesetzt ganz wichtig
titel platz mit interessanten titel
deswegen ganz wichtig so guten titel
anhalt verzeichnet das wird ein
wichtiger dass bis zum eingang überhaupt
verschluss unterpunkten gegebenfalls
erhalten und ganz wichtig formatieren
sie das bitte über die formate
produktion formatvorlagen wir sind sie
wie das geht
als es nicht wissen es nicht schlimm wir
haben dazu ein eigenes video erstellt
tinyurl.com hause halt einfach mal drauf
geben sind sie auch viel und da habe ich
so ein screencast gemacht wo ist dann
sehen wie das geht
wenn also als pdf anfangs genau erzählen
sie die anleitung okay das ist jetzt
noch wichtig da auf mich ein bisschen
genauer eingehen
wir werden wirklich wichtig dass sie am
anfang eine fragestellung auch werden
die für die arbeit land ist also es muss
systematisch problem knapp werden dass
es geht also gefahr ist dass nur seine
zukunft stücken dazu das gebe ich zu
das angefangen zu erzählen als wirklich
ein systematisches problem hinaus kann
man das kann man also wenn ich
systematisches ist manches thema
systematischer reifen bekommen dann das
müssen philosophie des problems und
nicht und kulturell ist unsere technik
philosophie ist es wieder soweit
es kann aber für diesen schritt ist
sagen sind fragen die existenz weiß
umfasst gezeigt wie existiert ist zu
anderen ist es eine eigene tätig besteht
ist die gründe dafür dass wir das immer
argumentieren gründe geben verteidigen
etwas ist mir ganz wichtig aber mit
dieser struktur gedankengang und er
sollte durch eine leitfrage anfang vor
der fast 8 likes ist schon mal eine
schöne ausbeute hier die zehn kriegt man
noch glauben dass er zehn minuten am 10
ich habe schon gesagt also gedankengang
nur nachweisen können sie mit fußnoten
machen oder in klammern direktiven
letzten teils sollten sie das
zertifizierte handlung das thema
sie können wie gesagt an tischen mit
weiteren punkten untergehen sagt
einzelner 223 unabänderlich deportiert
worden als der ertrag was ist jetzt das
ergebnis
das ist die antwort auf die live nicht
mehr von anfang vorgesetzt
natur wird seine sache schon das können
sie auch diesem format machen das können
sie auch anders machen das stehende
verein muss halt einheitlich sagt das
ist richtig so und jetzt noch ein
wichtiger punkt zum entdeckt er betrifft
ist hier also von einem plagiat zitiert
sie nicht wie die peter so sehr ich
dieses system schätzen sie das nicht
weil dahinter keine motoren stehen mit
namen die dafür kam es als individuum
sie brauchen immer einen namen der
autorin eine autorin die dafür würde die
qualität dieses artikel den sie da
zitieren auch nicht irgendwas im netz
fischen also die leine aus werfen oder
irgendwas aus zehn aus dem netz sind
heißt es sich gut da müssen sie schon
sehr sorgfältig auch der appetit des
internet jede menge möglichkeiten
suchmaschinen
ich stelle ihm noch digitale sachen zu
verfügung digital literatur
dann müssen sie sehr auf qualität achten
vermeiden sie unbeabsichtigt klar ich
will mich unterstellen ihnen oder mir
dass man das absichtlich nach zehn
jahren passiert manchmal leider so aber
wenn ich sorgfältig zu müssen gewisse
prinzipien berücksichtigt dann gibts
sowas nicht passiert so bilden sie sich
ihre eigene meinung und sehr gut zu
lesen dass sie nicht abhängig von
segmente entwickeln sich eignet und
akzeptieren sie werden wir es mit
premier texten zu tun haben
wir haben es geschafft
springen wir alle sechs cent ihren zudem
primär checks und machen sie sich
anmerkungen dazu
wenn wir so einen text ex-champion das
wichtige vom weniger bescheiden
eine ganz wichtige tun der zeile
digitalität oder digitalisierung
information zu unterscheiden was ist
wichtig weiß nicht wichtig es gibt so
viele informationen müssen sortieren sie
sich gleich gedanken dazu und werden sie
der these haben dann können sie in die
sekundärliteratur umgehen und die
fusionieren des fonds also was sagen
anders geht es in der natur können sie
dann wirklich hier ein bisschen sich mit
den anderen
so das war es meine seite haben sie noch
ja genau also ich habe meine seite www
film kam es komplett auch noch und ich
stelle auch die ganzen als ich schicke
ihnen die texte lesen herr unterstrichen
verteiler schickt steht dahinter auch
auf www jokers punkt mit und weil sie
auf der website sind sie überhaupt auf
der app verfügt genau als wenn sie auf
viele kastriert sind weil die app die
bezieht alle inhalte von der film cast
netzseite also meine ganze
zusammenfassung stiegen per e mail
stellt aber auch die seite lukas nett
und wenn es auf der seite flog ass net
es ist ja auch kein ende das ist
kein problem klar und zwar gerne auch
die getan aber es geht auch mit diesen
zwei worten bricht ja mal sehr hast du
noch was zu sagen ja ich freue mich auf
eine einigung kommt und diskutieren will
gm zahlt 14
die zuschauerzahl ist auch nachher und
96 zuschauen
bevor das jetzt ganz runter geht würde
ich sagen ich verabschiede mich bei den
teilnehmern hier und natürlich die
teilnehmer im netz und sie bekommen dann
verliert dem nächsten und mal mit der
zusammenfassung und sie dürfen auch
dieses video danach kommentieren das
sind nicht verflogen
und das ist jetzt ein youtube fest
drehen und da können sie danach noch
keine taten
also ich sie herzlich einladen möchten
dann bis zum nächsten setzen